So I'm actually going to give an overview of where I think our T for myeloma in 2026 is.
And look, I mean, I've been in practice now since 1990, and it is so rewarding to see what we've all been able to do in myeloma.
I mean, I remember when I started my practice in myeloma that I inherited from Thanos, I had no five-year survivors.
I mean, it was rare to have a patient with transplant.
So now I have a whole clinic of people in the little maintenance.
These are my disclosures, and I am a transplanter.
The death of transplant has been grossly exaggerated.
So we've already heard this.
Okay, so where can CAR-Ts go in?
And where are we now?
We are in the time when, you know, third-line and fourth-line treatment, they remain our go-tos.
Front-line treatment is first-line relapse.
It's now becoming more and more a conversation.
But you've heard there's all these other treatments that people can get.
And we can't forget.
The patient who gets a BCMA-targeted bispecific is somebody who probably won't get a BCMA-targeted CAR-T.
So sequencing is important.
We will hear in this meeting about treatment for smoldering myeloma and whether it will replace induction.
Okay, those are things that we're going to hear over the next three days.
It's happening, right?
So CAR-Ts are being done more frequently, and transplant is going away.
And I'm going to predict that the number of auto-transplants in five years is going to go down by 60%.
But I'm also going to predict that we're going to have a significant come-to-Jesus talk.
Because I remind you that DERA is going to become generic.
So DERA-RVD is going to cost very little.
Transplant is the cheapest way of achieving a complete remission.
And myeloma at this time is breaking the bank.
And I do think if we're stewards of our finances, we need to decide DERA-RVD, one transplant, DERA-Lend maintenance for two years,
is the solution for us.
And that's the solution for eight out of 10 patients with standard risk disease.
And that will cost less than $16,000 a year, which is probably what one month of teclistamab is going to cost, right?
So you really need, I think, yes, these drugs are great.
But if we're stewards of money, if we're managing our budget, this is something we need to think about.
So, and I'm going back to the two problems that CAR is going to have is, one, it's never going to be available across the world.
They're too expensive, except China, where I just came back, where they're like, you know, one center has 10 different CAR-T's.
It's like the flavor of the month.
Let's do this.
Let's do that.
And the other one's cost.
And then, so, and access is going to be a major issue.
And the one thing transplant has is that most people have access to their own cells.
So I'm bringing this one, right?
This is just one.
For drug induction, high-dose melphalan consolidation, DERA-Lend maintenance.
Standard risk disease, eight out of 10 people was the only treatment they're going to need.
And look at this bar, right?
I'm going to also predict that none of the randomized trials are going to overcome this bar.
I think the results are going to be very similar.
They're going to have to have 2,000 patients.
So the P gets to 0.05, right?
And then there'll be all these subset analysis.
So, I mean, I do think we need to sit back and say, wait a minute.
This old person like me really works, okay?
Let's not throw the baby out.
Well, let's throw out the, let's not throw grandpa out with the bathwater, okay?
So we're going to hear these studies.
So what do we know today?
High response rates for both IDA cell and CILTA cell, but only CILTA cell has long-term disease control.
If somebody's going to go to the garage, it's IDA cell.
I think IDA cell is not only in the garage.
It's like kind of like vintage old cars now.
Long-term side effects are more common with CILTA cell.
Lower tumor burden is always associated with better response.
And how we take people to CAR-T will probably be more and more important,
particularly in that third and fourth line of treatment.
Earlier use is associated with better outcomes.
Access is still an issue.
So the other thing is, as we think about where we put the bispecifics,
bispecifics will affect how we use CARs.
What we think we know.
I mean, we're all surprised that CILTA cell is when they both came
out, I went as a CILTA cell and IDA cell, it's probably Pepsi and Coke.
No, one is really, really good.
The other one is ah, just okay.
So dual binding sites of CILTA cell confer a better activity and more toxicity, ALC increases.
So we are learning how to use these drugs better.
And look, I have a hundred CILTA cells.
I have three patients with CAR-T colitis.
One's getting TPN.
We haven't been able to resolve it.
And I have three patients with lymphoproliferative disorder.
That's successful.
Six percent.
That's, that's one practice.
These are late, rare complications that if it happens 1% of the time, we need to treat a thousand people.
So one of us can start seeing what's happening, right?
I need a cell.
And I re I put spelt it wrong.
I'm sorry.
I need a cell.
We'll have equal efficacy, but less toxicity than CILTA cell.
This is aspirational.
We're not sure we don't have enough patients, but it seems like that the early data would support that.
CAR-T can be used more than once if PCMA is still expressed.
Yeah.
I think that's a very important issue.
I think that's an important issue.
This is, we can do this one and done, and if need be, we can repeat it again.
If the target's still there, I have the experience of patients failing.
Ida cell can respond to CILTA cell.
So once again, if we think about, well, maybe Ida cell, and we'll hear about this later on.
So I want you all to, I put Tara, these, I mean, and Vinay, thanks for this.
This is really a great meeting.
And there's a lot of things that I think is going to be important to focus on these talks as they come around.
Scott, Al, and Ken are going to talk to us today at 9:00 and 11:00 AM about, will CAR-T or Bytes replace high-dose melphalan as upfront therapy?
I just spread the seeds.
They probably, they could replace it.
The question is, are they going to be cheaper or better?
Is there any indication which Ida cell would be preferable to CILTA cell?
Al and I will just finish the study.
I'm going to present some of it where there may be a small niche for Ida cell.
Will Anita cell be superior to CILTA cell?
Peter's going to present that on Friday.
And then we'll talk about that.
And then there's a lot of SARS of Saturday is going to be a Byte versus CAR.
How will we compare CAR-T to Bytes in the upfront or failed salvage setting?
So a lot to come, a lot of discussions about this, but I am going to say, don't forget money.
Okay.
Really?
We need to be focusing on myeloma is now one of the most expensive cancers to treat.
And with Dara becoming generic, we really can make a change in how cost-effective and valuable this treatment can be.
Thank you very much.